He’s a politician, but not just any politician.
His biography is what you’d expect from
the protagonist of a best selling political
fiction novel.
However...
my friends, this is a flesh and blood politician,
with both a good side and a dark side.
We’re talking about Benjamin Netanyahu,
Israel’s Prime Minister and the most powerful
politician the country has had in
the last 2 decades.
But... you may be wondering, why are we talking
about Netanyahu?
Why is he so important?
Well, folks, what if I told you that this
man was the architect who basically designed
the Israel we all know today?
Yes, you heard that right.
We’re talking about a politician who has
so much character that he actually attacked
the very president of the United States in
front of his own Congress.
Yes, this happened to Barack Obama.
Don’t tell me
that isn’t one tough guy.
Well, the
fact is that Benjamin Netanyahu, or Bibi,
as he’s known in Israel, has done practically
everything in his country.
During his time as a soldier –remember,
military service is mandatory in Israel – he
commanded a special forces unit... and participated
in lots of operations like the ones we see
in movies, with Hollywood-worthy names like:
Operation Inferno and operation Isotope, where,
by the way, Netanyahu was shot while he and
his unit rescued a plane hijacked by the terrorist
group The Black September Organization
And as a soldier, he also participated in
operations in Egypt, Syria and Jordan.
But... that’s not all.
After finishing his military service, this
Prime Minister went to the United States to
study.
Where?
Well... in no other than, first, MIT, and
then Harvard.
By the way, here’s some curious trivia.
In 1973, when the Yom Kippur War broke out
between Israel and its Arab neighbors, Netanyahu,
who was studying in Boston, returned home
to re-join the special bodies forces until
the war ended.
But... let's continue.
The fact is that after studying in the United
States and spending some time working in consulting,
he got involved in politics...
where, again, he’s done everything... he
has been a member of parliament, an Ambassador
to the UN, Minister of Foreign Affairs, Minister
of Finance and, of course, Prime Minister
for 4 terms.
In fact, my friends, he’s about to become
the Israeli Prime Minister with the longest
term in office.
However, now his position of influence and
power is being questioned…
So, let's take a look at what’s happening
and why this man is an election-winning machine.
(CORNERED)
On February 12th, 2018, after a year of investigations,
the Israeli police recommended the Attorney
General bring charges against Benjamin Netanyahu.
See, the police state that there are clear
indications of corruption, bribes and influence
peddling.
They accuse the Prime Minister of having received
gifts of hundreds of thousands of dollars;
of having conspired to influence the media;
and also, of having protected millionaire
corruption in the multimillion-dollar process
of buying German submarines.
And, you know what?
This isn’t the first time that the Israeli
Police accused him.
They also did it in 1997 and again in 1999,
during Netanyahu’s first term as Prime Minister.
Back then, the accusations ended with no charges...
and now again the Prime Minister has made
it very clear that he won’t yield.
(“Nothing will have sway and nothing will
sway me, not even the incessant attacks against
me”.
Benjamin Netanyahu.)
The truth is that whether or not he’s finally
accused, Netanyahu is on the line.
By the way, in Israel, nobody is immune to
justice.
In the last decade they have condemned and
imprisoned a former prime minister, Ehud Olmert,
and an ex-president, Moshe Katzav.
So... if Netanyahu is guilty, he will pay.
Therefore, my friends, in this video we’ll
get to know Israel’s prime minister better,
take a look at his good and bad sides and
investigate what made Netanyahu such an important
character in Israel’s politics.
(KING BIBI: THE SAVIOR)
Netanyahu may not be the most amiable or popular
guy on the planet, but... one thing is certain...
Every time Bibi has come to power he’s done
so under very… very difficult conditions.
See, during his first term, when he came to
power in 1996, the country was greatly unbalanced,
with an uncontrolled public deficit and a
growing external debt.
In 2003, when he was appointed Minister of
Finance under Ariel Sharon’s government,
the country was undergoing its worst recession.
And the most current time was in 2009... just
when the country was suffering the consequences
of the great international financial crisis.
Well... in all these cases Netanyahu's recipes
worked.
And not only that: with his policies, Bibi
has transformed this country’s identity.
Thanks largely to his governance, Israel has
gone from being a place with chronic imbalances
and crises, a country that in 1984 had to
be rescued by the United States...
to becoming a prosperous country, with well-organized
accounts and a worldwide power in technology
and innovation...
Through all this, we can understand how, despite
all the controversy, Bibi continues to raise
passions, some against him, but many in favor
of him.
But many of you may be thinking...
Okay, but what were or, rather, what are Benjamin
Netanyahu’s recipes?
Well, here they are.
Traditionally, Israel was a socialist country,
with high taxes, a lot of regulation and a
huge government.
Well, Bibi’s mission was to change this
model once and for all and enforce another
that would organize the accounts and improve
the country's competitiveness.
Check this out.
( “You think that mathematicians and computer
engineers or mechanical engineers or doctors
are first.
They’re very important, but they’re not
first.
They’re second.
There was a country that had the best mathematicians,
the best physicists, the best metallurgists
in the world.
But that country was very poor.
It’s called the Soviet Union.
What comes first is markets.
This was the main thing that I tried to bring
to the Israeli economy, in my own way”.
Benjamin Netanyahu.)
With this idea in mind, in his first mandate
in 1996, his number one priority was to reduce
the public deficit, privatize banks and large
government-owned companies; and suppress capital
controls.
For example, at that time, Israelis had a
restriction on the money they could take out
of the country and for buying foreign currency.
Yes, we could say that the Israel of the early
90s resembled Cristina Fernández de Kirchner's
Argentina: A lot of public spending and capital
controls.
But... let's continue.
In 2003, when the country was undergoing a
terrible crisis, as Minister of Finance...
a minister of finance with a lot of power,
Netanyahu froze public spending and launched
a huge tax reduction.
For example, he reduced corporate income tax,
as well as individual income tax, by half.
See, when he arrived at the Ministry, the
maximum rate on income, in terms of wages,
was 64%.
When he left it was 44%.
A 20 point reduction in 2 years!
And when he came to power in 2009, he had
a similar recipe... less public spending,
fewer taxes and less bureaucracy.
In addition, in recent years, he managed to
get Israel, once and for all, to exploit its
huge Natural Gas reserves.
(“Israel bolsters Egypt ties with $15bn
gas deal”.
Financial Times.)
It was precisely because of this that many
believe Israel’s miracle would not have
been possible without this Prime Minister.
But don’t think that he only had good results
in the economic sector... not at all.
( “In the 37 months that Netanyahu held
office, Israeli citizens enjoyed one of the
safest and quietest periods with regards to
terrorism...
Of the five Israeli leaders examined [Rabin,
Peres, Netanyahu, Barak, Sharon], Netanyahu’s
policies with regards to the prevention and
deterrence of terrorism...were the most effective”.
Study by The Institute of Policy and Strategy,
The Lauder School and Interdisciplinary Center
Herzliya, 2002.)
Indeed, in addition to the economy, Israeli
society recognizes Netanyahu as having made
Israel a safer country.
A safer country and also, very importantly,
a country that is much more open to the world...
So much so that this Prime Minister has succeeded,
and listen up because I think this will amaze
you, in getting relations between Israel and
the Arab countries to go…
well... smoothly.
Wait a second, Israel and the Arab countries?
Let's look into this.
(THE EXTERNAL APPROACH)
Do you know the popular saying?
“My enemy’s enemy is my friend.”
Well... it looks like something like this
is happening in the Middle East... with Iran
and with fundamentalist groups like ISIS.
Check out the news that the New York Times
published on February 3rd, 2018.
(“Secret Alliance: Israel Carries Out Airstrikes
in Egypt, With Cairo’s O.K”.
New York Times.)
Pay close attention to this news bomb.
In the last 2 years, Israel has carried out
more than a hundred aerial attacks with planes,
helicopters and drones against fundamentalist
groups in Egypt, particularly against the
so-called Islamic State of Sinai.
That is, an Arab government, in this case
the Egyptian government, has authorized Israel
to carry out attacks and operations within
its territory.
Amazing!
But that’s not all.
Israel's relations with Jordan and Egypt are
better than ever, but they’re also growing
stronger with the other Arab countries, including
Saudi Arabia.
Yes, you heard that right.
Now, they still aren’t formal, but… they
are happening behind closed doors.
(: “There is an alignment of Israel and
other countries in the Middle East that would
have been unimaginable 10 years ago.
Certainly in my life time, I never saw anything
like it and I'm at the age of the State of
Israel more or less, so it's an extraordinary
thing”.
Benjamin Netanyahu.)
Do you want another example?
Well, listen up,
After 70 years of prohibition, and for the
first time, Saudi Arabia has authorized an
Israeli commercial flight to cross its airspace.
Since March, Air India flights between New
Delhi and Tel Aviv will cross Saudi airspace.
This may seem like a small step... but...
it’s not.
And you know what?
It’s not just the Arab countries.
This Prime Minister has set his sights on
the East and has established surprisingly
good relations with India, Australia, Singapore
and even China.
What’s more, Netanyahu led the first visit
of an Israeli Prime Minister to Latin America.
In 2017 he visited Mexico, Colombia and Argentina.
And in Africa, more of the same.
In fact, Netanyahu is the first Israeli leader
to visit this continent since the 1960s...
and many African leaders are delighted with
Israel's money and technology.
( “I saw diversity and richness.
I saw passion and productivity.
I saw young African entrepreneurs who are
building companies harnessing the power of
the digital age.
Africans are seizing the future.
Israel wants to seize this future with you.”
Benjamin Netanyahu.)
In short, as you can see, both in the economic
field, as in security and foreign policy,
this Prime Minister has many reasons to be
proud.
But of course…
not everything is a bed of roses.
(THE DARK SIDE.)
We’ve denounced it here on VisualPolik.
One of Benjamin Netanyahu’s greatest dark
sides, in addition to his corruption suspicions,
is his position towards the West Bank settlements.
Yes, Netanyahu supports these settlements’
continual growth, and as we saw, in recent
years his government has promoted a policy
to expand and consolidate them.
( “In its more than three years in power,
this government has been irrational, bordering
on messianic.
It is now increasingly clear where it is headed:
creeping annexation of the West Bank aimed
at precluding any permanent separation from
the Palestinians.”
Ehud Barak, former Prime Minister of Israel.)
And besides the settlements, Netanyahu’s
power relations with some magnates are also...
how should I put it?
Questionable.
For example, his friend and gambling mogul,
Sheldon Adelson, invested $200 million in
the Israel Hayom, a free newspaper that greatly
favors Netanyahu.
The question is, will he have to return these
favors?
Another significant part of Netanyahu's dark
side has to do with his way of doing politics.
Bibi is a tough opponent who has no qualms
about attacking his rivals through all possible
means.
That is precisely what he did in 1995 with
Prime Minister Yitzhak Rabin, whom he accused,
among many other things, of betraying Jewish
values.
The tension he generated was so great that
many detractors blame him for fueling the
hatred that ended with Rabin's murder at the
hands of an extremist.
His critics say that Netanyahu didn’t pull
the trigger, but that his lack of political
piety led to the tragedy.
So that, dear viewers, is the end of this
video about a politician who has a dark side…
but also a significantly bright one as well,
contributing to make Israel a much more prosperous
country.
But now it’s your turn, what do you think
of Benjamin Netanyahu?
Do you think King Bibi has been a good leader
for Israel?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did and don’t forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday.
Also, don’t forget to check out our friends
at the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine!
And as always, thanks for watching!